San Francisco Center for the book has an
excellent workshop that combines analog
and digital technologies in order to
show people how to make simple books
it's a two-part process the first part
letter pressing the second part simple
book binding let me show you how this
works this right here is a table top
platen press it's basically a manual
letterpress machine so way this works we
take a piece of paper and we square it
up right into the platen
grab onto this handle and give this a
nice heavy push you can see as this is
coming up those rollers are depositing
ink right onto the photo plate and then
it reacts itself push this down click it
into place and then bring it back up
tada
we got ourselves a beautiful letter
pressed image so now we've got our cover
letter pressed it's time to turn this
into a book it's a quick and simple
process using this book binding
technique that we're learning today the
first thing we need to do is fold our
cover sheet in half once we've got that
folded in half we can take some interior
sheets and put those inside and fold
them in half the same exact point now
we've got the basis for our book the
next thing we need to do is poke a few
holes take it all or any sort of sharp
pointy device like this and poke three
holes into this book you want to leave
about an inch next to the top and bottom
and one hole right in the center once
you got those holes in place get your
needle get your thread and starting from
the center of the book take this needle
and thread and put it right through that
center hole leave a couple inches of
thread from the end it's a little tail
flip the book over take your thread and
bring it all the way up to the top hole
and bring it right back through now
you've got that thread going from the
middle to the top and back out from the
inside of the book bring the thread all
the way over to the bottom hole
stretched all the way across the inside
of the book this is the final move bring
that thread back up through
that middle hole lined right up with
that two inch tail that you had left
before now you got these two pieces
together you can trim them so they're
the same length and you want to tie them
together and your book is bound and
there you go you've got yourself your
very own book made by yourself
now all you got to do is start writing
your very own warm piece you become a
famous author